let's get him on this now and talk to
the mayor of London city car very good
morning to you as Becky was saying there
you have said finally the government is
seeing sense on this but as mayor of
London couldn't you have introduced this
on TfL on Transport for London before
now first I do work on the government
say YouTube but the difficulties of
transport flood and going and lo more
than two months ago when I first call
for this is because we're not
responsible for all of transport in
London many of the network trails that
come in to London Underground trains are
coming to London commuter trains that
come to London are under our control
but I think it is important when you
have a national crisis that there's a
clarity of messaging and I think that
have been wrong for there to be mixed
message been given from us in TfL
bearing in mind that we want a national
consensus and many many Londoners rely
upon a national media for the news and
of course huge confusion but I do
welcome this change of mind from the
government it is it fair to put it as a
change of mind though I mean is Grant
Shapps was saying this morning I mean
they're all the London is a slightly
different scenario you know if
everywhere else you know the the the the
amount of people on public transport has
dropped to by what 99% in some cases so
this wasn't necessary up until now he
says well let me tell you why I think
the government's got it wrong on this
issue there are those issues they've got
a role in as well so more than two
months ago the evidence was quite clear
not just from expose in this country but
from the US Centre for control of
diseases and prevention from the
canadian chief public health officer
from austria from germany from China
from by other countries around the world
which is that although a facial covering
by itself won't stop you catching the
virus on top of all the additional
things we do
Washington has readily and thoroughly
thoroughly keeping your social distance
more than 2 metres if you were a facial
covering it stops you passed on the
virus if your priests symptomatic or
static and if other people where it
stops you catching it now the reality is
were the best one in the world there
will be occasions even when you are
using public transport and keeping your
social distance or going into a shop
where it's not possible to keep two
meters apart you're coming into social
interaction that's what as a
precautionary measure there is no
downside to doing so
and I don't understand why it's taking
this long for the government to reach as
few in relation to make any compulsory I
think it should be extended to shops as
well not because we're encouraging
people to break the 2 meter rule but
because human nature as it is and
sometimes they can be congestion this is
another step we can take to mitigate the
chances of catching the virus or passing
it on hasten to that thing a lot of
people would agree with you and yet it
was interesting as as one of the Vox
pops earlier on talking to one of your
Londoners who was saying maybe this you
know it is slightly problematic because
people wearing a mask do in a bad nature
of it feel a bit more protected and
possibly you know that is gonna you know
give them a sense that they can be a bit
more free and easy with the social
distancing well the other two Londoners
said the opposite the point is this
we're going to do whatever we can to
fight this virus my experience of
wearing a facial cover is it basically
is way of alerting others the virus is
here don't come close to me and keep
your distance I'm quite clear though by
itself this is a nice panacea but on top
of the other things that can make a real
difference and it's really important
that we do all your things keep your
social distance wash your hands readily
and thoroughly if you're out and about
use a hand sanitizer and we've got to do
all those things as well
what we shouldn't do is assume this
somehow makes you immune from catching
the virus it doesn't and that's why it's
really important we don't say this is
instead of all the other measures it's
as well as looks so far this morning
you've talked about the importance of
social distancing a number of times and
yet as mayor of London you haven't done
anything to to try to stop the protein
the black lives matter protests in
London well look who would want to stop
them no one in their right mind but
clearly there is a very big problem with
social distancing at these protests yeah
thank you for the way you just
introduced this topic is really
important we understand you and I why
people want to protest and make it clear
that black lives matter it's really
important the people who feel strongly
about this are able to protest but we're
also good with also going to be where
were in the midst of a global pandemic
and with the best of intentions wishing
to go and protest you may inadvertently
by being too close to somebody else
either pass the virus on or catch the
virus and how would you feel if you went
home and gave it to an older relation in
your home who you know ultimately lost
his or her life that's why my advice to
anybody who is going to be protesting
today tomorrow or Sunday that is to
please if you feel that strongly that
you've got to go in protest I personally
am NOT please make sure you follow the
advice keep two meters of park where a
facial covering just in case you can't
keep to me as a part once your hands
spread lean thoroughly and if you can't
try it with you a hand sanitizer - these
rules are there to keep you safe but
also your loved ones as well
what what's your take on what we're
seeing with that there was there have
been some disturbing incidents in London
in those protests I mean as we always
say in this sort of scenario that's
always the minority but obviously that
that changes the perspective that a lot
of people have when we see violence
against police officers or even against
camera crew I think the other day and
it's it's very difficult to keep tempers
totally calm in these sort of scenarios
isn't it I mean how how do you begin to
manage that do you think well the vast
vast majority of those protesting did so
peacefully lawfully and safely a very
small minority acting way that is
unacceptable
they were abusive and violent towards
our police officers there can be no
excuse for doing so and all they've done
the only injured are police officers and
be
Yussef towards them but they've
detracted from what is a really
important issue black lives matter
George Floyd's awful brutal death we
should be talking about and addressing
the racism the discrimination and the
inequalities black people face in my
city in our country and around the world
and it's really important nobody's under
any mistaken impression that it is
acceptable to be abusive or violent
towards a police officers or even
journalists I mean journalists are
they're doing their job they're
reporting this protest the idea somebody
would terminate a journalist or a camera
person I find objectionable and it's
really important we don't allow those
really serious points to detract from an
important issue which is the brutal
death of George Detroit the fact that in
2028 is still the case in the most
progressive city in the world London but
if you're born a black Londoner your
life chances and even your life
expectancy are less than many other
ethnic groups how do you think we start
to shed a light on all of this because
it's taken me by surprise in that I'm
someone who I would not consider myself
to be racist in any way but I guess I'm
not in a situation where I'm seeing
racist behavior I'm not mixing with
people who would behave in that way I
mean I'm lucky because my dear dear dear
friend and colleague Gillian I was able
to ring up and say how does this work
how are you affected what is going on
with all of this and she was able to
talk to me from her perspective about it
but for a lot of people that may not be
an option it seems to be shedding a
light on something that obviously
wrongly a lot of us just weren't aware
of
well what you've articulated is the
reality that both you and I don't really
understand what it's like to be a black
person and Gillian does and your black
viewers do and what we've got to make
sure we understand is we're not lulled
into a full sense of complacency what we
think and what happened to George Floyd
can only happen in minute
Minnesota America when you speak to a
black person most black people will tell
you that one of the things that went
through their mind when they saw the
brutal killing of George Floyd is but
for the grace of God but for the grace
of God that could have been me my dad my
brother and my son my cousin and that's
why it's really important that we
educate ourselves about what it's like
so we can have empathy with our black
friends members of our family or black
colleagues about what they're going
through and the reality is racism takes
many forms it can be covert it can be
overt what prejudice basically means is
prejudging and we can be guilty of
prejudging based upon preconceptions and
what the black community are crying out
for is a recognition that their lives
matter that's why I welcome what the
equalities and Human Rights Commission
of analysis today that as a result of my
request for them to look into the issue
of disproportionality when it comes to
covin 19 I think the brutal death of
George Floyd the disproportionality
we've seen with Kovac 19 should be a
catalyst for meaningful change to
address the structural inequalities that
leads the case in 2020 black people are
still facing racism discrimination and
inequality in my city in our country and
around the world Sadiq Khan I appreciate
your time this morning thanks very much
indeed